Secretary Clinton spent 11 days on her trip to Africa last month,...
...her longest trip so far as Secretary of State.
The trip included visits with heads of state and government...
...but also visits with women farmers in Kenya,...
...and with women in a housing project outside Cape Town in South Africa.
Women's rights advocates...
...say, Secretary Clinton went out of her way to shine a spotlight...
...on the plight of poor and abused women,...
...continuing her long years of advocacy for women's rights.
It became clear that Hillary Clinton had a special passion for global women's issues when...
...as First Lady,...
...she addressed the United Nations Women's Conference in Beijing in September 1995,...
...denouncing abuses of women.
During her trip to Africa,...
...Clinton boarded UN planes to visit the remote, eastern part of the Democratic Republic of Congo...
... a place the UN says has the worst prevalence of rape and other sexual violence in the world.
The atrocities that these women have suffered,...
...which stand for the atrocities that so many have suffered...
...and instill evil into its basest form.
The United States condemns these attacks and all those who commit them and abet them.
Secretary Clinton has chosen her close friend Melanne Verveer...
...as the State Department's first global ambassador for women's affairs.
Clinton has indicated that major decisions at the State Department...
...will be viewed through the prism of how they might impact women.